[Music]
the trial of Lori valo dabell has
resumed in Idaho now you may recall
She's accused of killing two of her
children and a romantic rival but you
may not be aware she has another son his
name is Colby Ryan and he gave emotional
testimony against his mother yesterday
Jonathan Vigliotti has more on that part
of the story
when Kobe Ryan entered the Boise
courtroom Tuesday 18 jurors watched as
his mother Lori Velo dabell mouth the
words my baby before the 27 year old
took the witness stand then they heard
an extremely tense jailhouse phone call
between the two you think you can hide
from me
seven-year-old J.J valo and 16 year old
Tyler Ryan went missing in September of
2019. roughly eight months later their
decomposed remains were discovered
buried on the property of her new
husband Chad dabel
my siblings and my whole family my dad
or everyone is going except for you and
you're in jail because of it if you rip
my heart out and you've ripped out
everyone in this family's heart out on
the stand Ryan described valo dabel as
being a loving and supportive mother for
much of his life he said he could never
picture his mother harming someone until
she met dabel the author of religious
doomsday novels does this not just seem
weird like the way mom acts in the
Netflix docu-series sins of our mother
Ryan said his mother began preparing for
the end of times like it's going down
like you're really gonna have to survive
like some Walking Dead like you're gonna
have to survive it I think Colby's
testimony was really overwhelmingly
helpful for the prosecution but CBS News
legal analyst Jessica Levinson there's
been this disconnect throughout the
trial where she's being painted in some
ways as a good parent but then how on
Earth could a good parent ever do this
to their children and he have to bridge
that Gap he helps to make those two
things reconcilable for CBS morning's
Jonathan Vigliotti in Los Angeles